you
when your values are clearing you making
decisions become easier Roy
making decisions can be hard when you
don't know what you stand your one word
is your core it's your guiding light and
makes all decisions easier if you don't
have that guide in life and you never
completely feel like you're going in the
right direction you'll constantly
second-guess yourself not being sure if
you made the best choice to spend more
time agonizing over decisions and active
been making the decision to improve your
life and the life of others when you
know your one word you can make the
proving that support repeal the
decisions that were difficult before now
become community to me we know if you
can start that business or not you know
if you should lose to that fit very nice
you know if you should marry that person
when I'm it's also easy for people to
understand who you are and how they can
help you everything becomes easier your
life your business everything becomes
much easier
you